when you press that snooze button you're
killing your dreams
so don't don't touch the snooze button
people might misunderstand you and say
are you obsessive why do the details
matter and all you have to do is smile
and say because the details matter i
can't do it
right i i can't i i don't have time or i
can't afford it it's the minute you use
the word can't
your brain stops working
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn how to stop killing your
dreams every day
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have a strict sleeping schedule with
jocko willink
from my perspective when people ask me
all the time though i lack discipline
how can i get discipline in my life and
no one wants to hear this answer
no one wants to hear it just do it the
one of the
first steps you can take to impose
discipline in your life is to wake up
early in the morning
because let's face it when the alarm
goes off
your you got your head on that soft
pillow it's all nice and cozy and warm
in there
you do not feel like getting up and so
he doesn't even have a snooze alarm he
doesn't ever hit this newsletter
you do and you should not you should not
that snooze alarm is that's insane
i call that snooze alarm the dream
killer like when you
when you when you press that snooze
button you're killing your dreams
so don't don't touch the snooze button
you're cute now where i get now some
would say that might be
a little extreme where people get
worried and people freak out yeah is
sleep is healthy sleep is good for you i
know that i get it and people say you're
telling people not to sleep no i'm not
telling people not to sleep you do six
hours every night
o'clock yeah i usually go to bed around
10 30 11 and i wake up at 4 30. so i get
five and a half to six hours almost
every night you know
and and sometimes i tell people i i i
think sleeping is good i do it almost
every single day
but but people will freak out and say
you're telling people to be unhealthy
i'm not saying that at all
i'm not you know if you need different
people are they have different genetic
needs for sleep i'm one of those people
that doesn't need much
of my four kids my oldest daughter
needs even less sleep than i do my
middle daughter sleeps more like my wife
my son somewhere in the middle
which by the way that means my middle
daughter she gets out of bed
when you get her out of bed in the
morning she likes to sleep
so i'm not telling people hey don't
sleep but i am saying put yourself on a
schedule
and you know you ask why i don't sleep
in if you sleep in if i sleep on in on a
saturday
until six o'clock ooh that night i'm
gonna have more energy and instead of
going to bed at
10 30 or 11 i'm going to stay up until
midnight because i got a little bit
extra
sleep well now that next day i'm gonna
sleep in a little bit more and all of a
sudden sunday i'm sleeping until seven
o'clock
now sunday night i can't go to bed until
one o'clock in the morning and you see
where i'm going with this
i go into monday with a lack of sleep
because i couldn't fall asleep so i just
the most important thing is set a good
wake-up time that works for you where
you get enough sleep and then wake up
that time every day if you can
rule number two start setting
appropriate goals with jordan peterson
you don't tell your kid here's an
impossible thing
why don't you go out and fail you say
here's something worth going after
here's a step you could take that would
push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at
right they call that within a time frame
within some time frame that's the other
thing you have to parameterize it with
regards to time frame that's right
and that puts you in the zone of
proximal development and that's a that's
a
concept that was generated by a guy
named vygotsky he was a russian
developmental psychologist and a smart
one it's where the idea of the zone
comes from to be in the zone
and when you're in the zone you're
expanding your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding
because you're succeeding and so you
want to set if you're good to yourself
you think okay i need to set a goal
but i need to set a goal that someone as
stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it
then you got then you've got it
perfectly because it's not so high that
it's grandiose or impossible that you
fail
necessarily and then justify your
bitterness it's like well i could do
well because that happens to people
happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well i
set a goal and i didn't attain it so i'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame
that's right you didn't calibrate it
properly yeah and and you're playing a
trick on yourself because you wanted to
fail so that you could justify not
having to try
and being a victim yeah which isn't
helpful you're still going to be
a victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so
you know because life is this life is a
challenge that in some sense can't be
surmounted so there's no way out of your
problem
but there are certainly proper ways of
dealing with it yeah rule number three
stop saying i can't with dan lok i can't
do it
right i can't i i don't have time or i
can't afford it it's the minute you use
the word
can't your brain stops working
stops looking for solutions the minute
years i can't well
that's it i can't do it right it rubs
you off your potential
it rubs you off the possibility
instead ask yourself how can i
see when people say to me why i i can't
stop my business
or i can't develop that high income
skill or i can
do that side hustle or i can't whatever
i always tell them does that mean
that you don't want to do it or does
that mean you don't know how to do it
because we all have the ability we can
all do something if
we want to could you do it if you really
really really want to
of course you could so the question is
it's not
i can't is either you don't want to and
that's perfectly fine
then don't say i can't just say i don't
want to
when your friends ask you to go out it
says well you know i
can't tonight don't say i can't just say
you know what i've got other commitments
i don't want to go just tell them i
don't want to go this is not something i
want to do
or maybe next time right decide
commit when you say well i i i can't
does that mean you don't know how to do
it because you could go get the how-to
there's so much
how-to on the internet you could go find
a way
you can you can take a program go to an
event learn from a mentor do
something you have the ability so we
place that word
can't with either how can i or
hey you know what i can do it i can
start that business
i can learn that skill i can learn from
a mentor
right i can quit that job i can go on
their vacation
you've got so much more potential if you
just believe in yourself
hi this is dan lok i want to share with
you a lesson from
evan carmichael's new book build to
serve
this section is about making money from
your purpose
you have to embrace that if you never
learn how to make money from your
purpose
you always end up needing a day job and
your purpose will become
a hobby if that sounds like a great life
to you
then i'm happy for you if not then you
need to figure out a money making model
that makes sense one that is consistent
one that is
significant one that can pay you so you
can quit your job and succeed
to the point where you are providing
jobs for others
and helping even more people you see
money is nothing more than a byproduct
of value creation the more people that
you serve
the more successful that you will be so
to have long-term success it's not just
built a lot
or built to sell or even build a skill
it is
built to serve and this book will teach
you exactly
how to do that rule number four trade
your life for worthy goals with bob
proctor
you know the law of success is a pretty
interesting concept
there's been books written on it stories
told on it
lives have been spent
looking for it
let's understand that everything
operates by law
the whole universe operates by law the
best definition of success i have ever
heard
was one that earl nightingale originated
way back 1959
he said success is the progressive
realization
of a worthy ideal well let's break that
down for a moment
success is the progressive continually
moving
progressive realization constant
awareness
of a worthy ideal an ideal is an idea
that you have fallen in love with
an ideal is an idea that you're
intellectually emotionally and
physically involved with
an ideal is an idea that you fall in
love with
success is the progressive realization
of a worthy ideal
so you don't ask are you worthy of the
idea
are you worthy of the good is
it worthy of you now now you're
getting in to law of success is it
worthy of you
you see what you're going to do is trade
your life
you're trading your life for whatever it
is you're going after
so you want to make up your mind
whatever your goal happens to be
whatever you are pursuing make certain
it's worthy of you because you're
trading your life for it the law of
success
calls for you to continually moving
toward a predetermined
objective in life and bringing your life
in harmony with the laws that govern the
entire universe
rule number five start paying attention
to the details with robin sharma
one of the things about the 95 percent a
lot of them are complaining they're
making excuses they want epic lives
but they're stuck in the group of super
the cult of superficiality
the top five percent the titans the
icons the a
players the world builders are very
different
they are not about superficiality they
are all about granularity
literally they have deseeded the lemon
wedges this is a metaphor that i teach
basically i was at a at a hotel in
luzerne switzerland
and i love fresh lemon tea and when they
brought the tray to me
i noticed that in the tray
was two lemon halves or and someone in
the kitchen had taken the time to
de-seed the lemon wedges
they actually deseeded them and when i
studied f1 teams and i actually had the
privilege to be
right with the team at a recent f1
and what i realized is f1 almost like no
other sport is really about deseeding 11
wedges
it was the smallest granular detail
the smallest calibration
that could make the difference between
a top one and a tenth place finish i
really want you to think about that
i really want to think about f1 f1 is
won
or lost in milliseconds because
each lap if you get a little bit faster
and you do it with the consistency
because consistency is the mother of
mastery
that is the difference between first
place
and not even placing and so if you look
at the top five percent
they are all about deseeding the lemon
wedges if you look at the top five
percent
they're all about calibration and people
might misunderstand you and say
are you obsessive why do the details
matter and all you have to do is smile
and say because the details matter and
if you study beyonce
study the great athletes you study the
great f1 drivers
and teams they do deseed the lemon
wedges
they do calibrate the pomodoro they get
oad that brain tattoo have become really
well known across the planet for an
obsessive attention to detail
oad that's what makes the best hotels
the best entrepreneurs
the best teams the market leaders the
best restaurants the best hotels
the best cars the best products the best
user experiences online
they are sweating the tiniest seemingly
innocuous
innocuous details to create over time a
user experience that
creates a go global base of fanatical
followers and rule number six the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
stop
fearing rejection with marissa peer so
we have a great fear of rejection which
is not surprising because when we're
born we
we have two drivers find connection
avoid rejection after all if a mother
rejects a child if a lion rejects the
cub
he's not going to be adopted it will
just die yeah
or it just starves to death and so we
know innately that our survival on the
planet is linked to not being rejected
and not that long ago you would have
died from rejection you know in
in a thousand years ago when they
banished you outside the walls of the
city or
you marooned a difficult sailor or you
cast someone out of the community you
pretty much died there was nothing out
there but purgatory
so we have a wiring that says rejection
will kill me
and that's why you had the fear but when
you can dialogue with yourself
no it feels like it will kill me it
can't kill me because
no girl can reject me unless i give her
my permission
right give them my power you can't
reject me unless i agree with everything
i don't like you because you've got
short hair i don't like your shirt i
don't like you because you're white not
white tall short
glasses not but when you say you can't
reject me
i'm i can't be rejected because the only
person you can reject me is me
you can talk to girls realizing even if
they say no you're not my type i'm with
someone
no thanks or even ooh not no they can
only reject you if you let that
in and we look at someone like james
corden who's certainly not
gorgeous but women love him because he's
funny
so funny and you know we like warm
people
you know the the packaging is all very
nice we'll as well have a great
packaging a great rapper and it'll
but they're unhappy and so our greatest
fear is to be rejected but the truth is
you could live in this apartment have
amazon deliver your groceries never see
a soul and you probably live until
you're 106.
yeah wouldn't i advise it but we don't
die of rejection anymore but we still
feel like we will
and all schools should be teaching kids
you cannot be
rejected you can ask for a pay rise you
can ask for crowd funding you can go to
someone to go here's my idea you can
write a book
speak in public because i with a lot of
actors who say i'm so scared of
rejection i'm like well
how are you going to be an actor then
you and i write books for everyone who
loves it there's going to be an odd
person because i hate this book and i
hate that writer too
but we don't let it in we have to laugh
about it when you give a youtube talk i
mean i've got
one of my talks got like three million
views and there's a few in there going i
hate a
stuck-up english um snob but they don't
know me because that's not me at all but
i don't go oh my god
i can never write another book i can i'm
okay because i don't let it in because
the only opinion that matters is my
opinion i know i'm not stuck up english
snob
so that can't hurt me now i've got a
special bonus clip on how to
take more action that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know where do you
need to stop fearing rejection let me
know put it down the comments below and
if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching and you
promise you commit to yourself that
you're gonna take
action we don't just watch videos here
believe nation we do something about it
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below if that's you
so i can celebrate with you too hope
without
action leads to pain and suffering
watching videos like this
is not enough it might give you hope but
hope that is not
tied to action and you doing something
will mean you never accomplish your
goals
the answer is always action it's hope
and then action and when that doesn't
work out
more action and when that doesn't work
out more action
so a couple years ago i was in new york
and i was meeting with my agents
and one of them said what am i trying to
do what's what's my vision what's my
mission what i'm trying to accomplish
and i said i wanted to spread belief i
wanted to spread hope
and he jumped all over me about the hope
like you want to spread hope
hope's not enough you can't just do hope
and and i remember walking aways like
what's he talking
hope is so important if you don't have
hope how are you going to
believe in yourself to go chase
something down without hope you got
nothing
right without hope and belief you got
nothing
where i realize the difference in the
thinking is the usage of the word is
people
hope things will happen it's not having
hope in something
it's hoping that it's gonna happen and
then they sit on their bed and sit on
their couch sit at home and do nothing
that kind of hope that's not a strategy
hope and belief is your first step
it's your first entry point in you have
hope that things will happen
but then you got to get up and do
something right
and so figuring out that message when i
was talking to my agent didn't come to
you right away
in the moment because at the same time
as much as i'm filled with hope and
belief
in humanity and what we can all do i'm
working
right i'm taking action i'm making three
to four videos every day
we haven't had a day in the past five
years where video hasn't gone up
every single day i don't know what that
consecutive streak is but it's long
it's big i'm working my face off every
day
in the achievement of my mission but i
also love hope and belief
it's why i have this channel so i have
my other channels i want i want to be
around people who've done a lot more i
want to learn from
the greats i want to learn from people
who know more than me and when i
see that it gives me hope that it's
possible
it gives me belief that it's possible
that if they can do it i can do it too
but you still have to do it the ability
to do it versus
actually executing and doing it are two
very different things
right the difference gap is going to be
the action and so
yes i want you to have hope i think it's
important but it's not the only thing
you got to make sure you turn that hope
and not just rely on the strategy but
you're doing the daily work to chase
down your dreams
if you want to know how to live your
best life check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there where i was operating my business
and i fell on some hard times and i was
sleeping
in my office it was hard coming